okay let's talk about this special
Comedy Central special Jeff Ross wrote
criminals live at Brazos County Jail you
really you go you went to with jail and
I looked at the special and uh I looked
at a bunch of excerpts from the special
and it's intense you're really in there
with these guys there's a lot of obvious
tension because you're in the cell with
them sure and you're making you you're
giving them a hard time I'm roasting
them yeah and I feel like if you can
laugh at yourself you're one step closer
to Freedom
so they had a sense of humor about it 90
of the people in jail right now are
coming out someday right so you have to
give them some hope give them some laugh
we have to humanize criminals we treat
them like dust so I thought I want to go
in I'm fascinated by the American
criminal I thought who are they really
why are there so many of them and I
wanted to sort of put a human face on
the inmate in America okay I met a lot
of scumbags too
what did you guys talk about while you
were in there what conversations did you
I mean besides doing jokes would you
ever have a conversation with them about
anything yeah we talked about why they
come in so much you know there's a lot
of a lot of these jails are essentially
mental health facilities yeah we've
closed up so many hospitals in this
country people come in just to sober up
and stuff right and a lot of people go
in for non-violent crimes and then they
get criminalized to once they get in
there so it's kind of heartbreaking so I
was curious about it I'm lucky I never
got busted I don't think I would last
very long I shot Suge Knight they never
caught me
I knew it was you we all knew it was you
uh you're a great audience they were
very receptive I roasted the women too
which was an interesting right I walked
into the women's jail I said if any of
you have been in here long enough to
find me attractive and uh they were
great the guys were really good sports
my opening joke was where my murderers
at
and three guys in the front row raised
their hand and you know you've got a
good crowd we have a clip here let's
take a look
that's where the white dudes hang out
does anybody ever get offended by your
tattoo
anyway good luck with the rest of your
stay in jail how many years 99 dude you
should get six million years for every
Jew that died in the Holocaust
this man
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
YouTube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]